Pergunta: "Pode usar o T3 sem usar o
T4?"
Pessoal, vamos falar desse assunto
polêmico no mundo da tireode, no mundo
endocrinológico.
Usar o T3 sozinho, sem o T4? Essa
pergunta chegou aqui e eu sei que muita
gente tem essa dúvida, principalmente
quem não tá se sentindo bem só com a
levotoroxina ou T4. Vamos entender
direitinho essa história. Primeiro, uma
aulinha rápida de fisiologia. Nosso
tireoide produz principalmente T4, livro
tiroxina.
seca de 80 a 90% da produção. O T3, que
é o hormônio mais ativo e potente,
representa uns 10 a 20. Mas, doutor, se
o T3 é mais potente, por que não usar só
ele? E é uma boa pergunta. O negócio é
que o nosso corpo é esperto. Ele
converte o T4 em T3 conforme a
necessidade através de enzima chamada
deodinasis.
É tipo ter uma poupança, que é o T4, que
você vai sacando conforme precisa o T3.
Porém, temos que lembrar que existem
muitas pessoas que têm dificuldade de
converter T4 em T3. E essa é outra
história. Agora vem um problema de usar
só T3. A minha vida dele é bem curta,
por volta de 24 horas. Isso significa
que você teria que tomar duas vezes ao
dia para manter os níveis estáveis.
Mas na metade dos meus pacientes t
dificuldade de lembrar de tomar o
medicamento mais de uma vez por dia.
Imagina o trabalho. Então com T4 que tem
minha vida de 7 dias, você toma uma vez
por dia de manhã é tranquilo.
Mas o maior perigo mesmo são os efeitos
colaterais. O T3 é muito potente, é tipo
dirigir uma Ferrari quando você tá
acostumado com Fusca. Tem que tomar
muito cuidado. Eu nunca tive problemas
sérios com T3, mas eu vejo muita gente
abusando e não respeitando essa
ferramenta poderosa. Pode causar
arritmia cardíaca, pode causar perda
óssea, sintomas de hipertiriodidismo. É
coisa séria, principalmente para quem já
tem problemas no coração. Então tem que
ficar muito atento. Mas, doutor, eu
conheço gente que usa isoladamente e se
sente super bem. Olha, existem situações
muito muito específicas onde isso pode
ser até considerado, por exemplo,
defeitos genéticos raríssimos na
conversão de T4 em T3, mas são casos bem
incomuns que dá para contar nos dedos. E
tem outro problema, no Brasil não existe
T3 pronto para comprar, é necessário
manipular. E aí entra outra preocupação,
a qualidade da manipulação. Já vi cada
história de horror com medicamento mal
manipulado. Eu gastei cerca de 7 a 8
anos para descobrir farmácias realmente
idôneas e que eu poderia trabalhar e
confiar sem nenhum tipo de medo. A
verdade é que boa parte dos pacientes
fica bem controlada só com T4. Se você
não tá se sentindo bem, antes de pensar
em T3, tem que investigar outras coisas.
Pode ser a dose que tá errada, pode ser
problema de absorção, pode ser uso
inadequado, problema de conversão, pode
ser outra doença junto, às vezes anemia,
deficiência de ferro, deficiência de
vitamina D, problemas emocionais. Então,
os guidelines internacionais são bem
claros. Eles consideram o T4 um padrão
ouro. T3 isolado não é recomendado como
rotina. Se algum profissional quiser te
passar T3 isolado, pense duas vezes,
peça para explicar o porquê, discuta
quais são os riscos, como é que vai ser
o monitoramento. Sua saúde não é campo
de experimento, OK? Yes.